uh you can't believe that the Bible is
the same as inel when um the Bible's a
corrupted version how do you know that
it's a corrupted version of the Ino when
you've never read it or seen it well
okay what what language did Jesus speak
you tell me he spoke IR how do you know
that because so um in Mark 5:41 he says
wait wait wait in where in Mark 5 I
thought that that's corrupted okay no
but you okay that that's relevant can I
say my point first that's irrelevant
back to that no because in mark it says
um so the reason why you know that Jesus
spoke Aramaic is coming from the
corrupted Bible right just because
something's corrupted doesn't mean it
doesn't have truth in it how do you know
that that's true okay well even uh
historic historical accounts say that
Jesus spoke you are relying on the Bible
for your historical Authority on the
life of Jesus correct well yeah in Parts
no not in parts that's what you're doing
how can you be using a corrupted book as
your historical Authority on the life of
Jesus because the same Source says Jesus
is the son of God this same source that
you're using to rely on the historical
reliability on Jesus's life proves that
Muhammad is a false
prophet hell is real hell is real hello
how you fine thank you how are you
pretty good thank you for asking great
um so do do you want me to talk about
this point or the in point before
whatever one you want to address okay
right uh fine I I'll go with theel
because that's what I was like listening
to so the question was what is theel um
theel is the Gospel of Jesus um that God
gave to
Jesus how long were you here listening
the past like four people I think four
or five okay so you've heard you've kind
of heard me kind of go extensively in
into what the inil was and the questions
I was asking yeah you asked about um 104
uh
1094 um about like Jesus speaking
Aramaic yeah all right so so the
question that I that I usually will ask
when you guys tell me that it's the
gospel that Jesus was revealed to Jesus
and Jesus was preaching I believe that I
have that gospel do you disagree with me
the the Full Gospel the inel I believe I
have it as in the full inel yeah there
the Quran never talks about a piece of
it yeah but okay no I don't believe that
you have the full now okay and why is
that well because the um the Bible has
been distorted over years so therefore
it's not the same as the original in Jew
how do you know that my gospel is a
distortion of the original in Jew well
that's because um that that's what we've
been taught but also because there are
uh there are some changes that have been
like there are some changes in the Bible
that you just said something very
important you said this is what you guys
have been taught as very important that
you that well yeah of course that's what
we believe yeah yeah but it's it's not
what your Quran it's not what your your
sunna says it's what your imams and your
shakes and your Scholars say today
that's what they tell you it's not true
it's your Quran your your religion
doesn't teach this you know so you're
you're parting what they say which is
not good it's not good at all because
once you once we actually start to you
know critically think about the claim
that's being made here we you can't give
any sub substance to what what you're
saying if I ask you how do you know that
what I have is a distortion of the
original inal the answer you give me is
that's what we were taught so you don't
really you can't you haven't verified
that yourself yeah let me just um try
and find the thing go ahead what are you
looking up there's yeah I think um so it
says in the Quran um the word of your
lord is complete in truth and Justice uh
this is referring to the Quran nothing
sh shall upgrate his words he is the
heer the omnicient we learn from the
Quran that all religions duties were
given to prophet Abraham and translated
to us generation to generation I think
there's another verse as well where find
what verse was that it was 6 uh 115
115 so chapter 6 verse 115 says that no
one can change the words of Allah right
yeah but you believe that people did
change the words of Allah you believe
that the in was distorted and changed
even though it was the words of Allah at
one point the the Divine work cannot be
changed but in terms of like the the
Bible it can be changed that's well
you're saying you're saying okay was the
inal changed or not yeah okay was the
inil the words of Allah yeah so you're
saying that the words of Allah were
changed yeah but the Divine words aren
unchanged as in okay so the is the exact
same thing as it always has been um we
don't have like the complete addition of
it or like whatever we don't have the
complete collection of it but uh in
terms of the the scriptures have been
written after those have changed um
those have changed compared when
compared to the original engine so so
the NG was not changed what could you
rephrase so the was not changed again
could you rephrase in terms of in are
you talking about the the same inil that
I'm trying go El the gospel that you
that the Quran says it confirms and the
the Christians have it in their
possession and they should judge by it
and believe in it was that changed no no
no notel okay so then when I have I have
the gospel I don't have a distortion of
the inel because the in can't be
distorted again the Divine word can't be
that's different to the actual
scriptures is the in the Divine word of
Allah yeah so it can't be changed and
therefore I have it well no because um
then is the full collection whereas in
the Bible and in the tah as well you
don't have the full collection the angil
is the full collection of what as in
it's the full word of God okay so you're
saying that I have the but part of it y
if you're saying that I have part of
theel my question is this how do you
know what part of what I have is the
inil and what isn't well how would that
be relevant to us because we believe
that the Quran is the true it doesn't
well it's it's relevant to to you
because you're a Muslim who believes in
this book of The Gospel and that it has
the true teachings of Jesus and you
believe that Muhammad came confirming
the teachings of Jesus so it's relevant
for you to know what the teaching of
Jesus was so that one you can even
verify that Muhammad is actually a true
Prophet okay but the the K is the true
word of God so is the confirms ver of
the teachings of Jesus well if you're
assuming that it's the word of God
that's fine I'm see I'm on the other
side I know that the claim is that the
Quran is the is the word of God unlike
you who's just comfortable with sitting
there and just taking that as it is I
like to go a step further and verify the
claim so when the Quran says things I
like to test it and I like to verify
what it says for example that it aligned
with the gospel I have the gospel and I
like to see if it aligns with it or not
which it doesn't now your way to get out
of that is oh well no you don't have the
gospel you have only part of it you have
a you have a distortion of it you don't
have what the Quran exactly was talking
about that's your way out of it which
the Quran doesn't say and you actually
go against the Quran because the Quran
says it can't be changed because it's
the words of Allah so you're in trouble
there everywhere you go with this you're
in trouble okay well so so your question
was the original question was what is in
jeel and that is the Gospel of Jesus um
that is what has been revealed to Jesus
through God that's still not telling me
what it is how so what what what is it
what what did what was what did what
contents does it have uh you know
because you're you're telling me that I
don't have it you're telling me that I
don't have the NGO let me ask you this
have you ever read the inel yourself
sorry have you ever read the inel
yourself no have you ever seen the
yourself no have you ever touched theil
yourself no but okay yeah go Point yeah
so how can you tell me that I don't have
it if you never seen it never read it
never touched it well well because so
the in and the torat is different to the
Torah and the gospel th those are
separate things um the Bible is separate
to theil wait how do according to what
well that's what the Quran says Where
where does the Quran say that the Torah
and the inil are are separate from the
Bible okay so it says um it says and if
only they upheld um the Torah the gospel
and what has been revealed to them from
their law they would have uh consumed
from uh from above them and beneath
their feet so it sounds like the Quran
is saying believe in the Bible observe
the Torah and the gospel and all that
has been revealed to you from your Lord
that's all the writings of the prophets
all the writings of the Apostles
everything that's all the Bible looks
like the Quran says I have to deserve
the Bible well no no
no this point comes back to the fact
that um the Bible is
corrupted okay so if it's telling you to
it's you're saying that the Bible's
corrupted so this verse just told just
told me to observe and follow a
corrupted book no it said inal it
doesn't say Bible it says does it say
all that's been revealed to you from
your lord and what has been revealed to
them from their lord okay so Torah in
what else did they have in their time
did they have like I don't know writings
of the prophets like Jeremiah Ezekiel
Isaiah Hosea Daniel do they have these
writings in the seventh century y good
did they have uh the ma Matthew Mark
Luke and John as the as their gospel and
do they have the writings of Paul and
the Epistles of Peter do they have these
things in their book with them yeah but
those are accounts those are what the
towns
these are This is Gospel this what they
called The Gospel it's what they had
with them so the verse says observe the
Torah and the gospel and all that has
been revealed to you from your Lord
that's all that they have that includes
the writings of the prophets and the
writings of the Apostles that's the
Bible yeah so I either go ahead yeah so
what we to is to well not to in the Quan
it says to believe in the Quran and the
Sunnah um and what has been said before
you sorry wait the Quran never said says
the Sun never believe in it never says
believe in the sun depends on the
translation okay go ahead anyway um fine
let's just say believe in the Quran um
which has been sent down to you and in
what has been sent before you which
refers to theil and the tour and all
that's with them actually not just the
tourah and the NGO but everything that
they have with them that's a separate P
but
yeah okay yeah but th those are it
specifically mentions the in own Torah
here it doesn't metion
the it doesn't mention the fact that
they're the same as the Bible and the
Torah well it never makes it a
distinction between them is the point it
never makes it never separates them you
said the Quran does but it doesn't well
you uh you can't believe that the Bible
is the same as inel when um the Bible's
a corrupted version you're just
repeating it again how how do you know
that it's a corrupted version of the Ino
and you've never read it or seen it well
okay what what language did Jesus Jus
speak you tell me he spoke IR how do you
know that because so um in Mark 5:41 he
says wait wait wait in where in Mark 5
wa I thought that that's corrupted okay
no but you okay that that's relevant can
I set my point
first back no because in mark it says um
it says T which are both Aramaic words
um which are both AR words the so no no
trust me darl I I'm with you so the
reason why you know that Jesus spoke
Aramaic is coming from the corrupted
Bible right just because something's
corrupted doesn't mean it doesn't have
truth in it how do you know that that's
true okay well even uh historic
historical accounts say that Jesus
spoke what historical accounts well uh
there was actually like a discussion
between nahan and Francis where Francis
um uh corrected him saying that Jesus
spoke out make um based on what what was
his Source what what what what was
francis's Source why wouldn't know his
specific Source because he's correcting
somebody who's saying something wrong
about the language of Jesus so when he's
correcting someone he's getting it from
somewhere where was he getting it from
that Jesus spoke Aramaic because uh well
for him because of the use of aramic
words in the New Testament boom so once
again this historian is relying on the
Bible as historical accuracy on Jesus's
love life isn't he like you did okay so
tell me this how again do you know cuz
you said that this Bible's corrupted how
do you know that the Bible which is
corrupted is actually true when it says
Jesus spoke Aramaic well because that's
a historical account it's a what it's a
historical account based on what though
what do you mean based on what what is
the
historical source that says Jesus spoke
Aramaic the Bible it's the Bible right
yeah that's yeah so the Bible which you
are saying is corrupted is what you're
relying on for historical information
about Jesus how does that work well not
just that he where was he born what do
you mean not just that you tell me where
was he born Bethlehem which is where
where you get that from okay but where
was okay where do you get that from what
do you mean where do you get it from
that Jesus was born in Bethlehem again
that that is also mentioned in the bible
yeah so once again you are using what
you say is
corrupted as your historical Authority
on the life of Jesus is that correct
historians have also proved that he was
born in Bethlehem based off what through
archaeology no it's not based yeah not
not just based on the Bible obviously
that the Bible makes it he was born
there the proof is through archaeology
what Archaeology do they use pull it up
for me okay
[Music]
do
I think all all it says it's just
accounts it doesn't it just says
accounts huh what
accounts what
accounts okay um what accounts dare I
say the gospel accounts that we have in
the Bible yeah that so that is also used
but that's used as a CL um it's proved
as well uh through the stories of Jesus
which ignoring the Bible there are
obviously other TS of that what other
wait excuse me because for some reason
it sounds like I mean what we're seeing
is that everywhere you go it shows that
you're relying on the Bible for all of
this information and but you're having a
problem admitting that it is the Bible
that is the source of all of this why
are you why do you have a hard time
admitting that well no I don't I do
accept that the Bible is a source but
I'm also saying that there have been
other
there's nothing there isn't any there
isn't anything else it's the Bible so
you are relying on the Bible for your
historical Authority on the life of
Jesus correct well yeah in part no not
in parts that's what you're doing you're
relying on the Bible as your historical
Authority on the life of Jesus how can
you be using a corrupted book as your
historical Authority on the life of
Jesus Jesus because the same Source says
Jesus is the son of God the same Source
says that Jesus died by crucifixion
under pontious pilate the same Source
says Jesus rose again from the dead on
the third day the same Source says that
Jesus empowered his Apostles to God and
spread the gospel that he's the son of
God who died for our sins and rose again
on the third day the same Source says
that Jesus appeared to Paul on his road
to Damascus and turned him into an
apostle preaching the message of Jesus
to Gentiles non-jews the same source
that you're using to rely on the
historical reliability on Jesus's life
proves that Muhammad is a false prophet
wait wait wait where did we get that
link from because this what you're using
that has the historical reliability on
the life of Jesus that's telling the
truth about what Jesus spoke where Jesus
was born where Jesus was from where he
went who his disciples were what he did
the same Source you're relying on
Muhammad contradicts and goes against
what is historically accurate about
Jesus well I'm not I'm not okay so the
historically the historical couns part
is separate to the like messages of
Jesus we think that the distorted part
is the um the fact that the Bible is not
the word of God that's the part that we
so what so something doesn't have to be
the word of God for something to be
accurate so when your source is accurate
on the life of Jesus the same Source
says that Jesus said certain things that
he's the son of God who came to die for
our sins which Muhammad contradicts so
Muhammad is going against history when
he goes against what the Bible says what
Jesus said well okay but how does that
prove if the Bible is 100% truth then
truth because then you're saying that
you mean 100% true it's either true or
it's not no you how again you are
relying on it as your source source of
information that doesn't mean that's
100% true I could write one lie in it
that's still a lie all right got got you
how do you know that the Bible is
correct when it says Jesus spoke Aramaic
and was born in Bethlehem how do you
know that it's telling the
truth okay you you mean okay I see what
you mean that's because I think the the
main part is the messages which are um
different I don't think the this this
the same source that you're saying is
absolutely correct on where Jesus was
from where he was born and what language
he spoke also says that Jesus said
certain things and taught certain things
and did certain things in front of
certain people and around certain people
in certain cities in different lands in
a particular Nation yeah but okay so in
the Quan we have similar words as well
um we have the same belief that Jus was
born of a virgin where sorry where was
he born though let me see if it says it
doesn't I'll just I'll save you time it
doesn't let me do you another
one where does the Quran mention the
language of Jesus what language did he
did he speak according to the Quran I'll
save you time it doesn't tell you sorry
let me just um find the point before uh
I'm trying to help you brother you're
not going to find it it doesn't exist
everything that Jesus matter of fact
here's another one this this one should
actually be easier you ready yeah how
did Jesus pray Jesus how did he pray he
in proos how do you know that yeah how
do you know that well that's not
something that you reject either how do
you know that see I can substantiate how
I know that how do you know that by the
way he also prayed standing up looking
up into his eyes he prayed walking he
prayed different ways one of the ways is
that he prostrated how do you know that
it says in I think it's Matthew Matthew
26:39 beautiful so again not just where
Jesus was born not just where Jesus was
from not just the language that Jesus
spoke but even how Jesus practiced his
religion you get from the Bible right
okay yeah do you not see the conundrum
here everything you know about Jesus
comes from the Bible that you are also
in your same tongue trying to say that
it's corrupted so either the Bible is
wrong with how Jesus prayed language he
spoke where he was from and you can't
trust it or it is accurate about Jesus
and the life of Jesus and you can trust
it and if you can trust it then that
means the Quran is false and Islam is a
false religion because it contradicts
what is reliable about Jesus okay so the
the fact that the Quran says in Jil
rather than Bible doesn't is is Gospel
the Bible is a collection of all those
books the Bible is just collection of
the Gospel of the Torah of the writings
of the prophets and the writings of the
Apostles the Psalms all of it fact that
it doesn't different between them um
that still doesn't prove your point
about um well yeah it still doesn't
prove your point that the Quran would
then contradict the Bible because so
what you're saying is that the Quran
contradicts the Bible but the fact that
theil isn't differentiated from the
Bible like explicitly doesn't prove that
theil isn't what is talking about what
is what is the do you know what the word
bible means no it means books yeah okay
do you know what the word for books is
in Arab in Arabic
Kabab do you know what the Quran calls
the Jews and the Christians people of
the what in what context in any context
what does it call us people of the you
should know of the book of the book so
if the Quran calls us the people of the
book in Arabic and if we were to
translate that into let's say Greek or
Latin it will call us the people of the
Bible okay your Quran is not against the
Bible bro it mentions it just in a
different language okay
uh it says people of the book but how do
you know that that specifically refers
to the Bible because you're just
translating a word I'll tell you how
because it mentions it it mentions the
what's in the Bible the Torah the gospel
the writings of the prophets it even
mentions the disciples and how they got
Revelation it's talking about what I
have not only that but it Direct
directly quotes from it bro I I can give
you where the Quran literally quotes
from my Bible you want to see it okay
yeah go ahead all right for example go
to chapter five of the Quran okay sorry
one second y go to verse go to verse 45
I think 45 545 okay yeah there he is 5
verse 45 now as you read as you get that
I'm going to go to the Bible and I'm
going to quote it and tell you ask you
if but sounds familiar all right are you
there yet 545 in the crow 35 or 45 45
45 yeah yeah I'm out all right go ahead
and read it what does it say it says um
and we ordained for them therein a life
for life and eye for an eye and those
for those and for an ear a for and for
wounds is legal retribution uh but
whoever gives up his right as Charity is
uh it is an expiation for him and
whoever did not dodged by what Allah has
revealed than is those who are theong
beautiful so now it's talking about the
Torah here it says we ordained for them
right it's talking about the Torah if
you read the previous verses so in the
Torah Allah ordained this judgment an
eye for an eye tooth for tooth Life For
Life wound for wound y y y right now
this is Exodus chapter 21 verse 23 to 25
listen if it sounds familiar but if
there is harm then you shall pay Life
For Life eye for eye tooth for tooth
hand for hand foot for foot burn for
burn wound for wound stripe for stripe
sound familiar yep literally quotes my
Bible Exodus chapter 21 want to see
another place yes go to chapter 21 yep
go to verse
105 wait sorry of the Quran yeah uh in
the Quran chapter 21 vers 105 y go ahead
and read that when you ready Sur
following the Heavenly record we decreed
in the scriptures my righteous servants
shall inherit the land all right so
Allah wrote now it said your your
version said scripture in the English
Okay so yeah it's also translated in the
Book of Psalms as well in the Psalms
correct in the
psalms now and it said my righteous
servants shall inherit the land right or
inherit the earth right yeah
yeah so now when I go to Psalms I'm
going to go to Psalms 37 verse 29 this
is what it says the righteous shall
inherit the land and dwell upon it
forever okay yeah quotes the Psalms that
I have in my hands today right okay uh
just go going back to the first point I
realized that the um the foregoing so
the PA of Charity is not mentioned in
the biblical passage the what the part
about charity isn't mentioned in the
Bible the rest is sorry but that that's
just the quran's the quran's little
input on that the law is there It quotes
the law that's from the Bible yeah and
okay so okay so the point about charity
was not mentioned in the Bible and this
verse um I believe was so reminding the
Jews of the law of the Torah um like
about murder and injury
right yeah okay um so the the verse
provides like a general description of
the law um found in the Torah mhm um but
again the point about charity isn't
mentioned in the biblical passages but
it's referring to what I have in the
Bible right yeah but the the point is
that the Bible does not have like the
exact same um like completed addition of
it nor nor does the Quran doesn't have
to quoted verbatim for it to be
referring to the Quran this is a
paraphrase of what's in the Bible it's a
paraphrase of what's in the law
yeah so we know that the Quran is
quoting from the Bible or paraphrasing
from the Bible is what we does it
multiple times I showed you two that
point it is yeah so in that point it's
the same this quoting from the Bible
Well it it is well no it's not because
well if that's what happened that's what
happened the Bible has its account the
Quan has its account that doesn't mean
it's necessarily are you saying are you
saying that it's not referencing the
Bible that I have it has a similarity
yeah so can we both agree and be
intellectually honest and understand
that your Quran is talking about the
Bible I have it literally refers to same
point yeah okay so you asked me how do I
know that it's talking about the Bible
that I have because your Quran quotes it
it paraphrases it refers to it almost
verbatim almost not verbatim but almost
that okay we we don't believe that was
100% corrupt that doesn't mean like
again that doesn't mean that every
single word is different obviously the
uh a couple of key ideas are the same
your Quran never says it's corrupt your
Quran never says it's corrupt if you say
it's corrupt you're going against the
Quran and so either way you go it's a
problem if the Bible is true as the
Quran says it is as it refers to It
quotes from it as you yourself rely on
it for information about Jesus then the
Quran is false because it contradicts it
if it's not true and it's corrupted then
the Quran is still false because it's
referring to corrupted scripture or
Allah's scripture got corrupted in the
first place where Allah says it can't
happen so the Quran is false there too
Noh no no matter where you go with this
Islam is cooked okay well again how how
does that Pro that um the Bible is the
same as inil brother there is no
differences of an of a different inil
some Phantom and that's different from
the gospel that I have nothing even when
you go to all the manuscripts that we
have even the ones even when you look at
the textural variance the meaning and
the message is always the same Jesus di
for
crucifixion doesn't mean the uh wording
is the same it is the same well no the
message and the meaning is still the
same despite some textual variance it's
still the same gospel do you get it yeah
but the textual variance means that it
is not the exact same like word for word
I agree and I I I our position is that
preservation is not based on word for
word copying if the as as long as the
message and the theme is preserved we're
good to go but can you see how that
becomes a problem over thousands of
years especially as no because if over
thousands of years with the different
manuscripts with the different languages
that they all have the same message that
they all have the same meaning in the
verses we're good that's actually I
would say that that's more of a miracle
than than uh trying to have it word for
word the same exactly but that's in you
know if you're if you're going to say
that word for word in order for
something to be preserved it has to be
the same word for word then you need I
mean you got to throw the Quran in the
trash because the Quran is not preserved
word for word letter for letter you have
different Arabic qurans that have
textual variance in these verses the the
difference between those is that that is
um for rec recitation that's different
to um Here We Go Again ladies and
gentlemen another Muslim who missed the
second half of this session dude it's
not about dialect it's about your Quran
having different words that change the
meaning of the text for example I'll
give you an example if you go to chapter
37:2 in the HS Quran it says a all you
Allah says to Muhammad you wondered
while they mocked that's the HS Quran
H's reading wait so what what um verse
was that chapter 37:12 if you're on the
internet just put in um chapter
37:12 HS and khif khif KH h a l a f HS
and khif comparison Surah 37:12 let's
see if it gives you that or if I just
have to show it to you on my screen but
hopefully it gives it to you already
chapter 37 Surah
3712 HS and KH compared
I'm going put that in myself to see what
pops up that'll save me time to have to
do this myself and give it you know all
right the first thing that popped up for
me is a question from Islam stack
exchange which is people asking
questions and people answering so I
don't deal with that but just for I
think it's worth mentioning is there a
difference in the Arabic wording of
Surah 3712 the answer yes there is a
difference Hamza alai and khif all
recited it as a 2 making it the Doer
making the doer in this verb I in the
recitation of HS yeah and so on it's a t
which is you yeah you see it yeah yeah I
mean I don't know about this specific
example but what I would think the
difference is caused by the perspective
from who it is I don't know who I refers
to in this case but here's the point the
word the word in both of thank you I me
the word in both verses are you know are
different in both qurans of the same
verse the word is
different pronouns are different because
if it's from a different perspective
then pronouns irrelevant it's not from a
different perspective it's the same
verse bro the same verse the only thing
that changes is the word and the word
changes who is the who's the the doer
who's the one being who's the one
wondering is it Allah who's wondering or
is it Muhammad who's wondering the word
changes who's the one who's wondering
okay and so my whole point is this now
however you want to interpret that is up
to you but the point is is that that's a
textual variant it's not word for word
the same you get what I'm saying yeah so
if word for word preservation is what
you consider as reliable then you have
to say that the Quran is not reliable
because it's not preserved letter for
letter word for word well I think I
don't know about this specific example
but I think the um it could be just a
slight like mistranslation in the sense
that I think wa it is meant to be his
but um say oh
mamad I wonder why they mock nope
because guess what even do you know who
IB Abbas is uh who sorry I IB Abbas yeah
iban Abbas and Ali they both read it as
a 2 where the one wondering is Allah
that's how they recited it IAH and Ali
they recited it as a 2 where Allah says
I wondered why they mocked so I Abbas is
the cousin of the Prophet the Inc of the
um the one who Muhammad prayed for to
have understanding of the Quran so was
he wrong look I speak on something I
don't know I'm not sure about fair
enough fair enough but this is the
weight that that you have it now when
you w to if you want to do your research
on this um you can go to uh AL C T C
he's the one who extensively breaks down
this difference of chapter
37:12 and you'll find in his as he's
breaking it down he's the one who
mentions how Ian Abbas and Ali and a few
other prominent ones used to read it
this way as a to where Allah is the one
Wonder right and how other groups other
people read it as aab where it's you
Muhammad Muhammad you are the one who's
wondering right so the whole it's not a
mistranslation it's not a mistake or it
could be I don't know
you'll have to see see which one is the
mistake then is a or muham is the one
wondering is that the mistake or is the
mistake Allah being the one who wonders
which one was the original who knows but
the point is is that it's not um it's
not word for word the same so if you're
going to say that the Bible has a
problem because it's not the manuscripts
are not word for word the same then I
then you have that problem you have to
drop the Quran because the Quran is not
preserved word for word the same you
understand what I'm saying okay apart
from this do you know of any other
verses yeah there's a lot there's a lot
of other verses I mean me personally I I
don't normally read um like different
versions of the car because they they
aren't really that different but yeah so
I my point is that I wouldn't know about
this uh I wouldn't be able to like speak
on the reason for that of course no
worries and I'm and I'm not asking you
to speak on it because it's it's it's
just a it's just a fact man it's just
what it is it's just the reality I'm
only addressing your standard by which
you're judging by you're saying that the
Bible has a there's a problem with the
Bible having textual variance even
though the message and the meaning is ac
across is the same but the fact that it
has textual variance is a problem which
for us it's not but for you it is so all
I'm saying is is that okay if that's a
problem for you then the Quran is a
problem for you because in reality
it has textual variance okay yeah yeah I
see your point so that's all I'm saying
man but I don't think that you're going
to drop the Quran with these textual
variants would you well I mean I don't
know what like the reason for the
textual variance is so I wouldn't um I'd
have to actually like educate myself on
that before I like think of anything we
we we talk about this stuff extensively
there's a YouTube channel two Arabic
speakers ji and DLC ji and his wife d DC
they both speak Arabic and they know the
sources extremely well J and DLC that's
J Ai and DLC on YouTube and they talk
about this stuff all the time they show
the sources they show the scholars what
they say and it's not complicated like
they the way they break it down is clear
for anyone anybody can get it I I'm I
learned this stuff from them I learned
this stuff from them this is how I'm
able to show you this stuff and and you
know and talk about it you know to an
extent so if you want to learn about it
J and DLC they go live and they they let
Muslims come up and ask questions or
they show sources like that they do that
D yeah ji and d and do on YouTube
subscribe to them and I even I even go
live on my own channel God logic
apologetic I go live and I have them on
a lot where we talk about the stuff we
we literally did like we did two or
three I think it was three three
sessions three
sessions we did three sessions on this
topic and Muslims came up they engaged
they asked questions and even Arabic
Muslims arabic speaking Muslims came you
know trying to object to certain things
and then eventually had to admit like
okay yeah yeah that that's a difference
yeah that that is difference but you
know the Quran is still true type stuff
they acknowledged that there were
differences but they still held on to
the Quran yeah okay um I mean I have to
look into that specific point because
again I don't know and I will also look
at um giant DC see what uh they talk to
see what they like think about that um
but yeah again I wouldn't be able to
talk on that sure so so this is where
we're at man we're at the part where we
see how the Quran uh points to the Bible
as being authoritative the books that
the Bible collects it calls the Jews and
the Christians the people of the book
alkitab which means book which is really
literally what Bible means Bible means
books where the people of the books it's
translated into Latin or whatever it'll
be saying people of the Biblia people of
the Bible right um it refers to my Bible
specifically refers to It quotes from it
paraphrases it right from the Bible that
I have says that we should judge by it
says that I should observe it and I have
nothing to stand on if I don't I'm a
wrongdoer if I don't everything that you
know about Jesus comes from the Bible
how he practiced his religion how he
prayed prostrating you get that from the
Bible where he was from you get that
from the Bible the language he spoke you
get that from the Bible so even you are
relying on the Bible as a historical
Authority on the life of Jesus so you
have to also take into account what he
taught how his the historical Source
you're using tells us what Jesus said
and did which would also go turn it's
you know which is also a problem for the
Quran because the Quran goes against
what historically Jesus taught and did
while at the same time affirming
it's Source that's what we call the
Islamic dilemma bro it's a problem for
Islam yeah I offer you a better way man
look think about this think on it I
offer you a better way man I offer you
to believe in the gospel believe in the
Bible believe in what the prophets
taught actually read it read what the
prophets taught about the Messiah look
at what the prophets taught and see for
yourself it's consistent it's continuity
and how the Quran is the outlier you'll
see if you just read for yourself stop
listening to Islamic scholars stop
listening to bias imams and shakes pick
up the book read it for yourself okay
well I mean um I would have to do it
from both sort of points of view um but
yeah I definitely will do that um I'm
not 100% sure on this topic so it's not
like I know the exact reason why that's
an argum like um like why that's a case
in certain arguments that you mention
but um yeah yeah definitely have to
research more about it from of course
all good of course well I don't want to
I don't want to pile on too much of you
so I I'll leave you with that okay but
you're you're welcome to come back
anytime bro you're respectful you listen
you you know you think so I can talk to
someone like you all day really um so
yeah come back and whenever you feel
like it I'm live often follow me message
me if you have a question if you want to
Source or something or I have a question
hit me up let's let's stay in touch okay
all right thank you all right take care
of yourself man see you bye